I guess women in my life always lead me
into into wisdom and so this was
actually a essentially I supposed to
meet a woman at this place and I didn't
know what it was I couldn't even
pronounce the word I'm and I can't make
this up I mean I walk into this place
and to me I automatically stop as I open
the door and it looks to me like a scene
from Yentl you know there's black hats
and and long black coats and sits us
hanging out and I didn't even know
what's its is worth strings to me I
wonder if I pull them what would unravel
you know and I sort of it was one of
those old scenes from a commercial that
people my age we remember called the EF
Hutton commercial or tree walking and
everything stops and people are looking
at me I'm looking at them and my mind is
going ok these people are probably
wondering what this large black man is
doing here and then I talk to myself and
I said yeah and I'm wondering what this
large black man is doing here and so
high i just looked around and then this
woman comes over me this very Orthodox
working woman it says to me you know
you're supposed to be here to meet
so-and-so well she couldn't make it and
I'm like Oxford is England's just like
America and comes to my personal life
and I turn around leave and she says to
me wait a min stop would you like to
join us and it really was a question and
changed my life and you know I'd like to
say that I'm so popular that i double
booked my dates on weekends but i really
had nothing else to do and no excuse to
give the legitimate like I'm sorry no I
have another person I'm supposed to meet
so she SAT me down at the only seat open
which was a her see that she got out of
it was crowded banquet it was the
holiday I'd never heard of called
simcoe's Torah and I was sitting down
right next to this rabbi who in every
visible way was different than me I'm
643 he's you know in a five-foot we have
four or five six whatever i'm black he's
white he's got a lot of hair on his face
I didn't and but immediately somehow
across the Gulf and this was nineteen
ninety-two when the crown height rights
were going on and he actually was Ted
studied in crown heights but somehow
right immediately something connected he
and I and in a way of real substance of
friendship and as we began to talk about
what our passion
were and at that point I was just so
enamored with writing I just left
Stanford where I was writing a column
for a local newspaper far as the student
newspaper and was just and infatuated
and excited and inspired by authors like
you know Richard Wright and James
Baldwin so I talked about what I wanted
to do and he talked to me that oh I
write columns all the time and we had
both written this column about the
concept of tolerance and he wrote in
England I was in United States of
America about this idea of tolerance
that was sort of saying the same thing
to tolerate another who's different than
you as we always say we should tolerate
each other would really it's sort of
cynical state of mind that says I'm just
tolerating you that if you disappear off
the face of the earth I'm no better off
or worse off as opposed to recognizing
every single soul you meet as a gift
from God they were all we all have
divinity in our essence and if that's
the truth then we need each other that
we need should understand each other we
should work to get beyond tolerance and
embrace each other for who we are and
both of us having written the same thing
immediately we start having this
powerful conversation and you know by
the end of the night he's teaching me my
first Hebrew words because I don't drink
alcohol and he offered me a drinking
when he said he said according to
Judaism you don't judge a person until I
think one of the words kisa caso kah so
to you are how you see them with their
purse when the worse is purse how they
are when they're angry one of them is
anger and how they are when the hell
were there it drunk one of the words
means cups and he says I can never truly
know your soul well I didn't drink but
by the end of the night I have a
yarmulke on and I'm dancing around with
the Torah and having a blast and I ended
up coming back and I think what we ended
up doing was showing true love and love
is a willingness to seeeeee in some ways
sacrifice self and embrace other as self
and but in order to do that there's got
to be real understanding and so we
started doing book exchanges let me give
you a book written by James Baldwin you
give me a book written by Elie Wiesel
let me give you a book by about
maimonides let me give you a book
written by the boys and we both found
each other's literature so exciting I
remember like Malcolm X's autobiography
tore through it and at that point was
wearing an X hat and said it so close to
the could keep on underneath so it was
just exciting journey but we kept coming
back on Friday nights just for
fellowship spiritual fellowship we found
very rooted in spiritual and the idea
that we all are children of God and I
sort of bringing friends of mine
Christian friends of mine Muslim friends
of mine so on and so forth and before
you knew it it became the hip place to
hang out on friday nights they were
there were people of all different
faiths all coming together around this
sort of seminole leader seminole
religion and many ways as maimonides
vision was that judaism would be a light
unto Nations it was teach the world
about monotheism and things like that
and these powerful conversations we
invite speakers and by the end of the
year he said to me he said to me you
know Judaism is not about proselytizing
and converting it's really about
teaching goodliness teaching godliness
there's principles like the seven
noahide laws and things like that and he
said you embody a lot of these values
and a lot of the ideals of universal our
kindness and goodness I'd like for you
to lead this or this this group student
group at first I said no I said I knew
you were crazy all the time now I see
your Meshuggah as well and he said we
wrestled it arguing I finally said you
know I'll take this risk and the ways
wasn't a risk at all it was just joining
together with another brother of mine in
many ways is so different but with a
common vision of the world and what
needs to happen I think for ultimately
to bring about as he would say a
messianic era as I would say to bring
about the kind of universal love that
this world really needs
you